l'heure est désormais au dépistage
massif ici en afrique du sud une grande
campagne de tests a commencé le
gouvernement table sur 30 mille tests
chaque jour et des équipes de détection
arpente ainsi les rues dans certains
quartiers faisant du porte à porte et
des unités mobiles circulent également
aux camionnettes à travers le pays
une logistique qui est facilité par
l'expérience de l'afrique du sud en
matière de lutte contre le vih et la
tuberculose car des installations
existent déjà pour effectuer des tests
le pays entend aussi se servir des
données de localisation d'opérateurs
téléphoniques pour retracer parcours des
personnes testées positives et pour ces
malades et bien des sites de quarantaine
sont mises en place pour les isoler
l'afrique du sud se prépare donc au pire
et dans la région du cap notamment un
appel au volontariat a été lancé en
direction des médecins et infirmières
pour venir renforcer les équipes en cas
de besoin ces prochaines semaines en
attendant le confinement en est à son
onzième jour sur 21 qu'il est entré en
vigueur le 27 mars dernier malgré le peu
de cas de contamination alors recensé
assez rapidement aussi les écoles ont
fermé les rassemblements ont été
interdits les liaisons aériennes
suspendue elle très vite ont été mises
en place des dispositifs de gel
hydroalcoolique partout à l'entrée des
commerces des restaurants des lieux
publics est signe de la réactivité des
autorités sud-africaines pour tenter
d'endiguer la propagation du corps la
viole